hundreds of supporters gathered from the
early hours at the capitals airport
hoping to greet the former president on
his return to Brazil
but federal police had other plans
forcing bolsonaro to leave by a side
door
and shattering his hopes of an open Car
Parade through the streets of Brasilia
Souza had traveled 1500 kilometers just
to greet her political hero
she says bolsonaro supporters have been
vilified since his election loss and was
disappointed that she could not see him
we have been called terrorists when most
of us are peaceful Brazilians who are
committed to a cause work hard to get
bolsonaro back in power
tensions in Brazil have been high since
bolsonaro failed to formally acknowledge
defeat in October's divisive election
and then refused to pass the sash to his
successor president
instead he flew to Florida last December
two days before leaving office
one week later thousands of his
supporters stormed the presidential
Palace Congress and the Supreme Court
claiming the election was rigged
is at risk of being charged and
imprisoned or made ineligible for future
office he is the target of 20
investigations
he has been accused of spreading
disinformation about the election result
and of allegedly stirring up the
insurrection
but his supporters believe he will lead
them to victory in 2026.
bolsonaro has already laid out his
mission he has said he will travel all
over Brazil to Rally support for his
Liberal Party from now until the
Municipal elections next year he hopes
to help elect at least one thousand
mares and strengthen the grip of the
Brazilian conservatives
it's a global scenario told his party he
will pursue
[Music]
we are practically holding 20 of the
benches in Congress in addition having
the support of parliamentarians from
other parties we have a majority within
Congress and we want the best for our
country today the bull is in your court
I'm sure that you will leave Brazil to a
safe haven is with great pride that I
return
himself has said that he
turn of the former president from his
self-imposed Exile has raised hopes
among his supporters they say he's the
only one capable of uniting the
Brazilian right again
Brasilia Brazil